Dr. Bock, if you could please introduce yourself with your name in today's state in our location.
My name is John Block. Today's date is August 5th, 2014, and we are in the family room of my house.
And we're going to talk a bit about your career and pharmacy and your association with OSU.
We want to start off at the beginning. You were born in Yakima, Washington.
That is correct. Is that where you were raised?
Yes, all the way through high school and then Washington State University for bachelor's degrees and master's and university with cons and then Madison for my doctorate.
What were your parents backgrounds?
You mean business-wise, education-wise? What does it give us a sense of view?
Well, my mother was born and raised in Yakima. It's a funny story. Her parents were in probably the last group of pioneers.
They're actually listed in the Yakima Valley Historical Museum on some wall plaque.
They actually came out in a pioneer train. They were on a wagon train.
She was raised there and born on a farm. I think my granddad was a foreman or something like that. It was not his farm.
The interesting thing was her birth was never registered because she was a girl baby born out on a farm.
And I was not pertinent later on after she was married to my dad who I mentioned just a moment. They got a court order.
Her is a court order birth certificate which then paid off when Medicare came along because she could prove her age.
My dad was raised in Buffalo, New York.
And in those days there was no State University in New York.
Per se, they were the State of New York supported different majors at private schools.
So I think forestry was at Syracuse, engineering was at Cornell, things like that.
And he was a twin and second born. He had an older brother and his dad being German.
Said the oldest son was the one who's going to get to go to college.
So my dad took commercial courses. And in the senior year in high school his dad, my granddad, told him whether there was enough money for him to go to college.
Well, my dad sort of said he didn't take the college trip courses so he was not eligible for any New York school.
So he went to the University of Pennsylvania, graduated from the Wharton School of Business Administration.
As my dad said before Harvard stole the faculty, hired onto the Firestone Tire and Rubber Company.
And Harvey Firestone with Junior was in his training class.
And then as he looked for a position to be a Firestone Tire salesman, he found that the Eastern Washington,
or actually the Central Washington District, had done very poorly.
And he had been advised, don't replace every tiring salesman who is real successful.
Because you'll go down, go to one that is not successful, you can go up.
And he was successful. And he, Basie, I think was headquarter in Yakima, but his territory taken all through the Eastern Washington.
And they small wheat towns, clodous wash techno, I guess over the coal facts.
Maybe up to Spokane that I'm not sure.
My mother, I guess they were going to a baseball game somewhere and got married.
Drove a Model A Ford for their Wharton trip back to Buffalo, which is where he was then going to work.
He resigned from Firestone.
And as they've gone, I guess into Canada crossing Detroit Windsor,
then into Canada, then across the Peace Bridge, into Buffalo.
And the immigration customs guy on the US side, of course, asked who they were, where they were born.
My dad said he was born in Buffalo fine.
My mother was very naive and said she was born in Yakima.
And he asked her what part of Japan was that.
And she didn't have a birth certificate as I indicated.
Well then, so he got in, obviously.
The Depression struck.
And what people didn't realize was that depression was roughest in the industrial parts of the United States,
because the manufacturing stopped, the people were all laid off.
And the rural areas, things weren't great, but people ate and they bartered.
So my dad decided we're going to head back out to the state of Washington.
And he had business contacts who could help him get established.
And so that's how he got back west, left Buffalo, and got going in Yakima.
Basically, Billupman, and a few oil gasoline distribution business, few oil before natural gas had come in.
Did you have any siblings?
I had, my brother died a couple years ago.
He was eight years older than me.
And I say he died a couple years ago.
He graduated from Washington State also, ROTC, back in the days of the Korean War.
Of course, remember there was a draft on.
And stayed in the military.
Got to be a bird kernel.
And so actually, I attended and participated in his internment in Arlington with the full case on, banned the whole ceremony.
What were you're just screwing up as a boy in Yakima?
Well, that's interesting.
I guess I dabble around photography.
I had a dark room.
And would shoot pictures.
I had a 30-fold, old, Argus C-335 millimeter camera.
I graduated from a Brownie, Kodak Brownie.
And we developed my pictures.
I never did do color.
I did family photo-Christmas cards.
Took some of the pictures around the church I grew up in.
And I got on the stage crew.
Those days was Yakima Senior High School, the only high school in town in those days.
And it was also the city auditorium.
It had a nice auditorium, full stage, dressing rooms and the basement.
And we would be, those are the stage crew.
If we worked for a somebody putting a show on, we would get paid.
So I got my every spouse position.
I even got a key to the stage area.
And learn how to get along with the janitors.
I was on the stage crew when the Air Force band came through.
And there was a stage circus with a little baby elephant in the basement.
That upset the janitor because he made a mess.
And of course, there were the plays and things like that that were put on.
How much earlier, Snitch, an interest in science or in pharmacy?
I guess it was just the science courses that we had to take curriculum in those days
and it was pretty regimented in high school.
Well, even I come out of the era of junior high.
So grade school went through sixth grade.
Junior high was seventh through ninth and high school was tenth, eleventh and twelfth grades.
And had very good science teachers.
They all had a master's degree.
It's pretty much in their subject matter, supposed to a master's of teaching.
And I guess that was how I got my interest.
I didn't pick pharmacy right away.
I went as an undeclared major at Washington State and hunted around and went to the counseling center.
And sort of looked at it and I thought, you kind of had the pre-pharmacy curriculum
as what I was doing.
And it was one where I didn't think I'd be stuck in a lab.
I would know the public well, I ended up in a lab anyway, after grad school and academia.
What's all about your experience at Washington State and the undergrad and the budding pharmacist?
Well, we lived in, there were two political parties in those days.
There were the Greeks and the independence.
And there was none of this that freshmen lived in the dorms their first year.
If you pledge, you went to your Greek house immediately.
The person who was in charge of the dorms believed in a strong dorm system and loyalty and so forth.
So if you went Greek by golly, you went to your fraternity or sorority for the women.
And of course, there was no such thing as coed dorms.
The boys were on one side of the campus and the girls on the other side of the campus.
And if you didn't get the girl in on certain times, you got a campus and you had to give her a dozen roses, which happened to me once.
And the dorm I was in was nice.
They were sweets of rooms. They had washbasins in the rooms.
There weren't the long hallways.
It was, I won't call it semi-private, but they were nice and they were quiet.
They had real thick walls between the rooms, so plaster on a lathe.
So it was good and we had a good reputation.
We got one of the higher grade point averages.
There was this type of competition and an intermural, which I didn't participate in.
My worst sport in school was PE.
Just as an aside, you'll never guess who my high school, physical education instructors were.
Bobo Braaton, before he went off to Washington State to be the famous baseball coach.
He was a high school PE teacher.
What was the curriculum like for you in pharmacy as an undergrad?
I've seen it was somewhat different from what students did.
Well, we had compounding.
It had a lot more lab involved.
So I said we'd compounded ointments and creams and suspensions and elixirs and all that type of stuff.
Otherwise, medicinal chemistry was medicinal chemistry based on what was known in those days.
Pharmacology was pharmacology. Pharmaceuticality was pharmaceutical.
It just, there wasn't as much known.
The concept of a receptor was just that, a receptor.
It had never been one, it had never been isolated.
Drug design was in its infancy, which is basically a group of compounds.
And just the companies would screen them.
And if they got a hit, they got a hit.
The key fob of her amendments had not yet passed.
So you had to tell it a might situation occurred.
I'm trying to remember when the efficacy requirements went in and they screened all the over the counter drugs and reformulate a lot of them.
Because the brands were popular, but they had to take ingredients out because they couldn't prove they were effective.
So I would say the science and the efficacy requirements have greatly increased over the years.
And now, there of course, into all the re-evaluate and the type of cystic that are used and how much are the companies.
And I don't mean this an anti-company thing at all because I'm sure some of the same stuff went on the lab and then University Labs too.
I was just looking at the number of papers that are being retracted nowadays coming out at University Labs and institutes and so forth.
But when you throw out a bad study, when we were out at the bad study, it was probably a very important study.
And I said something you better be alert to.
So I would say there's a lot more in the stay-in age of electronic and communication and so forth.
May, may, may, may, the public may be better protected.
By the time that you'd finished at Washington State, it was pretty clear you were going to be a farmer since it seems.
What about it? A field deal? What was your... sparked your interest, I suppose, in pursuing career in pharmacy?
Well, I knew I could not do medicine because you know, as I'm holding my hands here and there's a slight tremor.
I have what's called familial or idiotractic tremor and hair different grandmother through mother through me.
And at least in medical school in those days there was a required surgical rotation.
And you would not want me to be your surgeon.
And in fact, in physiology we had to do surgeries on rabbits and we all had to take turns.
And I didn't do too well in my rabbit.
Unfortunately, I had three other people on the team that could bail me out, but I am...
I was one of those kids in grade school when testing the measurement came along.
First grade, I couldn't get my bow tied on my shoe. I'm real clueless with my hands.
So you did want me in medicine at all or dentistry or anything like that.
But I can count poor Lycan stick, I mean, which is of course, and convey knowledge to the customer or the client.
But the follow-up later became Dean at Washington State, looked at my record and said basically,
I think you ought to consider graduate school.
So that's just a faculty member took an interest.
So you put me off in that direction?
You had an mentor of sorts.
Oh, definitely.
Well, you went to Wisconsin briefly after you were in Washington State.
Well, I was there for four years.
But did you do some post-grad work at Wisconsin right after you finished your bachelor's degree?
Am I right about that?
After I went to bachelor's degree and I stayed at Washington State to get my masters.
And then went to Wisconsin.
And I was there for four years in a typical period time to get a doctorate,
at least in the chemical-like pharmacy sciences, came here.
So I graduated in basically 1966.
Tell me about your graduate training at Washington State in Wisconsin.
Washington State was a traditional, I mean, for the masters was a traditional medicinal chemistry,
had a research problem, make a series of compounds.
And I wasn't there for them to be tested.
But that was basically it.
And of course, you take the appropriate chemistry courses with, in fact, most of the courses were in chemistry,
except for an advanced course in drug design.
At Wisconsin, did you want me to jump to Wisconsin?
Yeah, I want to be ready.
Okay.
At Wisconsin, again, they didn't have a course.
It was interesting.
I was really going to work for a different chemist.
And he moved on to Kansas.
And I say, I ended up at Wisconsin.
And that's an interesting story.
Okay.
God will be able to have a lot of inches on your, I guess it's no longer in here.
I guess it's no longer inches on the table, it's a silicate chip.
One's in there.
Right.
I applied to three different graduate schools, or I wrote to three different graduate schools,
and applied to two, if I remember right.
I told you the person I was interested in at Wisconsin had moved to Kansas University of Kansas at Lawrence.
But they sent me old outdated catalogs.
So I just shrugged it off.
I had, there were a couple of new faculty members at Washington State who were both Wisconsin grads.
So I was sort of getting input from them at the same time.
And they knew the personalities of Wisconsin.
I applied to the University of California at San Francisco, which is where the pharmacy,
that's the medical center of the University of California.
The original medical center for the University of California assistant there more than one now,
and applied there and was accepted with a teaching assistantship.
I got accepted at the University of Wisconsin with a research assistantship.
And they, these two fellow faculty assistants,
I just grabbed the research assistantship and you can start right out near research and speed things along.
So I did.
And it was very interesting.
In late spring, I got a letter from the University of California, San Francisco,
saying they would award me a Smith Klein and French fellowship.
I think probably I was a runner up and whoever they originally gave it to turned it down and went somewhere else.
But by that time I had made my choice and it didn't seem right to back down.
I think when I'd accepted.
And it would have actually been unethical for California to accept it me then.
I don't think they would have cared.
But it turned out well. I got my doctorate. I met my wife this December,
would be our 50th wedding anniversary.
So it worked out well at Wisconsin.
Tell me about the environment there. How it was different from what Washington State?
Oh.
Wisconsin was definitely a research university. It was definitely publisher parish for the faculty.
The undergrad is as the former dean told me on my exit interview.
He said, you want to understand the role of the undergraduate.
They provide the tuition and support so that you faculty can do your research.
So treat them nicely.
I mean, that was, I had no idea fans and butts about it.
You've got to keep in mind Wisconsin had a longer tradition that a lot of the big 10 schools.
Because they had the Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation.
So when you drink your glass of milk with vitamin D in it,
the royalties from that patent that's gone to the University of Wisconsin.
If you are using warfront as an antiquite on her rat poison,
the warfist Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation, that was all discovered at Wisconsin.
And on it goes. So they were in the business full time.
A known mistake about it.
And a lot of us sort of had a reaction too, like do we want to be assistant professors in this type of environment?
So when the opportunity came to come to Oregon State,
it seemed nice attractive because there was more emphasis on the teaching.
Well, before we get to see how I'm interested a little bit more in your research as a graduate student, how I progressed.
Well, it went well. I got publications.
It was a different type of problem. It was not a drug design problem.
My major professor was actually in the natural products.
And he was very successful at it.
But he had what was called a physical organic problem.
He made his claim to fame by actually finding an error in a structure that the late RB Woodward developed.
The only error was in the stereo chemistry. But anyway.
So he wanted to follow up on that. And so basically that was my problem.
So I did not have to do natural products isolate and hope I got everything done with the 10 milligrams I could get out of the plant.
I could just keep making my comp, my simple little compound and keep running tests on him so forth.
So it was that type of problem.
But otherwise it was a standard graduate university graduate chemistry lab.
Lab benches. Everybody in there working postdocs and graduate students.
We came to OSU in 1966 and told me a bit about the decision to move back to Oregon.
It was mainly jobs were kind of tight academic jobs.
I had a chance to interview at the chemical abstract service at the American chemical site as the parent of it in Columbus, Ohio.
And I could tell that was all going to get computerized at some point.
I thought that would be a good mix. And I think I would have done well.
But this other position came along and I talked to a major professor and decided to take it.
So it turned out that there was an opening also at the University of Nebraska, which I guess I really wasn't that aware of.
But a person I later knew and he and I became co-authors on the first textbook I was involved with.
And he said, oh yeah, he knew about the, I'm not sure he got his PhD.
But he knew about the Oregon position.
And later heard it was got filled in and realized it was me until later we met with comparing notes.
And I glad took Oregon because things have not gone well for pharmacy in Nebraska.
They were in Lincoln, then they got moved to the medical center in Omaha.
And the provost of Moodung was all very pro. Then Nebraska start half financial problems.
There were two pharmacy schools in Omaha and the governor said, you know, I need one. Why don't we let Creighton be it?
I don't know what he was still against having one of the state school, but anyway.
So they had budgets cut. They did say the school, but when budgets cuts like that happen and good faculty aren't going to go there and some leave, that would not have been a good situation.
This has been a growth situation in the pharmacy school here has grown professionally and enrollment too, but professionally.
What were your initial impressions of the University of Corralis?
Well, Corralis was a nice beautiful college town even, I shouldn't say even in those days.
And I like the fact I could even bicycle, I had a bicycle from Wisconsin.
The interview was weird. I have to say because my colleagues at Madison were going for their various interviews and were talking about these research presentations they had to give and all this.
And I come out here and there was no affirmative action. None of that type of stuff. I was hiring the backseat of the Dean's car.
In the townhouse, Lutel, after 24 hours of interview. So anyway, things were... I thought, well this is good, I like this. So I had a job.
And my wife fortune is very flexible. And she had gone to school out of state and so forth as far as her bachelors and traveled quite a bit. So she was fine.
And she's enjoyed this town too very, very much so. Climate wise, it's superior to the winners of Wisconsin. And then you have the hot muggy summers with the mosquitoes and Wisconsin.
So, no, this is a very pleasant place to live.
How would you characterize the department of that pongier rail? Very heavy teach and orientate oriented and very, very structured.
It was a small faculty. It was a... No, I believe it was a school of pharmacy. And then I think under President Vickor...
It got to be Oregon State... It was already Oregon State University. It was not Oregon State College. A time I got here was Oregon State University.
And some of the academic units were colleges and some were still schools. And he finally said, look, I guess he told the Dean's, I guess. I wasn't.
That if you want to be a college, you can be a college. So, I guess we changed our Notre-Head. We became a college. And that meant we had departments.
But the worth that, I mean, medicinal chemistry at a department head and two faculty.
Pharmacidics had a department head and three faculty. Pharmacology had a department head and two faculty. I mean, it was crazy.
And I think there was a department of pharmacology, which is the old term for natural products. And I think they had two faculty.
And so the Dean didn't have faculty meetings. This was Charlie Wilson. He had department head meetings. And so these four sort of senior guys sort of ran the school. And the rest of it sort of picked up by osmosis. What the heck was going on.
And then we have faculty meeting once in a while. So, was there any sense of the history of the program that had been around since 1898? No. And in your research, you, whatever you can find. And I don't mean this negatively. But there was a former Dean.
His name was Clausum. And he committed suicide. And I actually had a graduate student who was an undergraduate here at the time that occurred.
I don't, to this day, know exactly what the situation. I obviously, man, had depression of some type. And there was some story that he
had run up gambling debts and so forth. But I honestly don't know the truth. To his credit, he was a Minnesota grad, as I understand it. And he brought one of the first Rokai Rokai's, the National Pharmacy Honor Society.
Tori, I think I remember what chapter we are. But we're one of the very early chapters. Is it a Phydelta? No, no. Phydelta Kai is a pharmacy fraternity. Co-Ed. There's no them on Pope Kappa's side that I was a member of. No, no. Rokai Rx. And there used to be a women's sorority. I think it's fallen by the wayside. Well, I know it has an Oregon state.
And there were a faculty who were Phydelta Kai who wanted that. That's why basically Phydelta Kai used to be both Phydelta Kai and Kappa's side. Kappa's side fell by the wayside. And Phydelta Kai has been the predominant. And I am sure high active it is anymore.
But Rokai still initiates top students each year. There is also a leadership group which is fairly new. And I don't know what is. And I think it's Rokai to join induction ceremony, spring it.
Los Alsturder, CH2M Hill, Blum Nye Center, somewhere like that. So after Clawson died, they brought in Charlie Wilson, who had been at Minnesota and was down at Texas.
And he was co-author of a very famous well-established, became very well-established medicinal chemistry textbook. It was Wilson and Gisffold. And Ole Gisffold was also at Minnesota. They started at Minnesota. And it was the first. So when I had as an undergraduate even. And they had got to be multi-authored. I ended up being co-editor for a couple of years of an author of a chapter or two or one or two editions.
Anyway, he came and his idea was he was told he was supposed to try to start increasing the research capability. So he was hiring young faculty out of grad school. There was a new pharmaceutical.
And I was a pharmaceutical. And I was a pharmaceutical. And I was a pharmaceutical. And I was able to get anything big. I would get smaller grants. And the pharmaceutical person went off to the industry. And it was Dick Mollhouser.
There was an addition to the building made. That was just going on when I interviewed. They were in the finishing stage. I came in December for that. Well, it was a Christmas break.
And in fact, you know how you usually pay to bring a person out for interview. No. I took my wife to Yakimov for the first time at Christmas time. After Christmas, we drove down to my dad or my mother's car and drove down to Corvallis. Went through the interview.
And I think I might have got reimbursed for mileage later. He did pay for staying in a motel on the way back because there have been quite a bit of snow. So got me cheap. There was no this hiring start-up money. Start-up your lab. But to answer your question, when I came, the faculty had were scared around campus because of the addition.
When I arrived in September, they were all back in the new building. And the labs were set up. And I was pretty impactful in these days. Potentially yes. It did start some research going. And they started to see some increase in graduate students.
The other speed department of pharmacy administration with maybe one other faculty member in the department that I'm not sure made over to.
There's an interesting story that goes, Charlie Wilson worked very hard to get that addition put on. And the ledges, he got approval. And I guess those days it definitely had to go through the legislature.
And the new offices are all to be labs with fume hoods and the faucets and the gas outlets and so on.
He went to NIH. Money was a lot more plentiful from the federal government those days. He went to, and I think it was NIH, make sense.
And got a grant to outfit these offices as labs. And unbelievable. The state said, we budgeted X amount of money. Since you got this federal money, we're going to subtract the state money.
And so they had he sat down the plans and put X's through marking out which lab offices could have labs in which ones would not have fume hoods.
Did you get one ahead of life? I had one ahead of hood, yeah, because I was a new young assistant professor. But yeah, that's how strange things were in Oregon, for example.
Which department were you in? Either we were called medicinal chemistry or pharmaceutical chemistry, I forgot which.
At the industrial level, the term pharmaceutical chemistry is what it's an academic level we might call pharmaceutical, it's formulation.
And the drug design is in medicinal chemistry. But academia, seeing like pharmaceutical chemistry, was the drug design area.
So what were your responsibilities in this initial position? Well, I was very surprised. I was going to be teaching a lab in medicinal chemistry. I didn't think there was such a thing left.
So I taught a lab in medicinal chemistry, which took a lot of time. What do you mean by such a thing that was left as a sort of an older approach to?
Yes, yes, oh yeah, they did various side building. I honestly gosh cannot remember where these experiments came from and so forth.
But we slow it took years to get rid of that lab. I did not teach in the farm. We had a pharmaceutical analysis course and there was a lab in that.
And those labs slowly disappeared as more didactic material got into the course.
I ended up starting the second year. I taught the biochemistry course because that was my minor at Wisconsin. And the story on that is very, very interesting.
I see a smile. So maybe you know part of the story.
The dean and one of the other senior faculty had daughters, I think both daughters, who were in pharmacy and were really complaining about the quality of instruction from the Department of Biochemistry.
It used to be biochemistry and now it's biochemistry and bio physics. And one of the complaints was that each quarter they would keep changing instructors.
And this would happen each year. So over in the pharmacy school you couldn't get a reading on what was being covered when the students coming in who had had the biochemistry course because there was this rotation of instructors going on. It was a service course.
And the pharmacy students would start to complain when they're kind of a cohesive bunch and that made the biochemistry faculty angry.
And finally the dean says, I'm going to yank the course. Start teaching a John and try to make it unique.
Well they had a rule in those days. There was to be no duplication of course work on campus. And they really got a tight about it.
But I did and I started with the course towards a clinical approach and a nutrition approach. So I started to change a lot of stuff. I mean it was still basic biochemistry.
He still went through intermeneinary metabolism. We still went through protein chemistry. No labs though.
And then chemistry carbohydrates and then what was known about DNA and RNA and of course that is mushroom. But I picked up and in start to cover diabetes biochemistry diabetes the biochemistry of hyperliplidimias before there was much known about hyperliplidimias.
And then I wrote a paper for the American Journal of Pharmaceutical Education on a clinical approach to teaching biochemistry.
Most successful paper ever wrote all my 100 reprints disappeared. They all got requested. I gave an oral presentation at the American Association College of Pharmacy. And it was packed.
I was on a roll. It was not what you call research. Well the chair of biochemistry and other faculty member came over to have a meeting and said we teach that. Well they didn't teach that approach.
And they find it up and we just want you know that we teach it too. But you can go ahead and teach your stuff. Okay. I got along actually with most of them over there. Fine. We got along.
But every so often it would come up. One of the faculty members over at Dixon in the dressing room and it came up. You know his faculty members in pharmacy and this other this fellow biochemistry says so how come it is you keep teaching that biochemistry course.
There was a physical chemist in our living room. My wife was very active with American fields or was AFS and there was a group in our living room. And the physical organic chemist said, hold the sun, blurt it out. You know you really have no business teaching biochemistry.
It wasn't even his department. That's really. Somewhere along the line I had a different reputation, different parts of the campus I guess. It's kind of fun.
Particularly once you get 10 you're what they're going to do.
But eventually when we went to the doctor pharmacy program.
We met with Chris Matthews, the chair of biochemistry and basically they took the course back and it was a higher level course that we had the students in rather than the service course.
I told them what I was going to continue teaching which was the nutritional aspects and some of the diseases. They said fine can I have our students come? I said sure. I don't think I ever did.
So everything was fine. My understanding now what they have done is they're only requiring the first two years first two some quarters of biochemistry because we're still in the quarter system.
And I'm not sure how they're handling the molecular biology. It has changed so much. And with the heavy research emphasis. The faculty are extremely focused doing their teaching.
So you and you get such a turnover of faculty going on in the biochemistry and that's our courses too.
There's very rare where you'll see one faculty member sees a course from again and there'll be a course coordinator who basically is job is to make sure the grades get submitted on time to the registrar.
So there's a lot of this. You might say it's a medical school model that's going on.
Did it seem that the pharmacy was resistant to change in terms of the curriculum early on or?
No. In fact, just the opposite. We see like we always had curricular upheavals. And that was going on nationally too. There are all these trends that you got changed to clinical pharmacy. You got to do this. You got to do that. You got to put in communication skills. You got to put in cultural sensitivities.
Oh no, no, no. There's. It was always in state of flux. Always going through transitions. And what do you do about a student who was not right in sequence in the curriculum changed that what do you do for them? No. No.
No. That's just the opposite. We were very fluid.
Tell me about setting up your research. It was you.
Uh. That got off to a slow start. I basically had some undergraduates. And I really had trouble getting going. I did one based on my PhD and got the paper published.
But I was always fascinated what's called quantized structure activity relationships. And it's a statistical method of drug design. And I end up with a graduate student named Doug Henry who was very good of statistics.
And that's basically what Doug is where I got the bulk of my papers. I had a couple other graduate students who got papers. But overall, I basically got into the drug design area.
I was publishing in that area and would go off to the Gordon Research conferences. Start to get a little bit of money from the.
Oh shoot. Army. Army. And it was not the chemical warfare bunch. That type. And go back to their research conference citizen.
Did certain things with them. I mean, published and nothing was classified.
And I met it. I made a contact at a Gordon conference. So let's say it was that. So that's the base what I did. I don't have that many papers.
And I Denver really got any real big grants. I think the biggest ever goes 10 or 12,000.
Was the model pharmacy the model drug store still around. Oh, when I came. Well, there was a prescription lab. And they had cubicles. So the students learned to dispense. And there was phones. And there are some faculty member grad student would function as a doctorate point and prescriptions.
So there was still that. Yes, but that's disappeared.
What was your sense of the kind of climate on campus when you arrived in this is the 60s preceded and. Well, when I bicycle onto the campus that late September.
First day of classes. There was a group of freshmen in green beanies. And I was dumbfounded. I could not believe this because I've been to Washington state.
It was not such thing as green. I mean, it was just a regular university. I could not believe it.
It was a college. It was an ag school. When I saw the PhD curriculum. It was loaded with coursework. And the story goes. And I have one emphasize story could I never heard it face to face.
But the dean of the graduate school in those days believed in lots of coursework because he knew that Oregon State PhD graduates were not going to go to the big research universities. They were going to go to the smaller schools and be teachers. So they need to take a lot of coursework so they could teach a number of subjects.
Oh, that's interesting.
When obviously I knew I wanted to get tenured and in my third year I got a letter from the president university. Dr. Jensen saying you have tenure.
I like this. I like this place.
I wasn't promoted yet, but I had tenure after three years. And I had to go through any sort of.
Then he retires and goes off with the Rockefeller Foundation somewhere. And they bring in President Nick Vicker, Robert and Vicker, who was a one man show. There's no question about it.
The one man show. Turned out he was a member of our church. And so at our annual church picnic he was there with his wife. And it was a OSU faculty member who was taking him around introduced. And so I got introduced to him.
Well, it turned out that I had learned ahead of time that yes he was a graduate university Wisconsin, his PhDs in biochemistry. And a person who I actually taught my major professors course to the undergraduate of Wisconsin.
And there was an individual who was on sabbatical from industry. A man named Dave Perlman, who was just a gentleman. And he gave the bottom lectures in this course.
And somewhere along the line Dave Perlman told me, oh, Mac, was my picker, was called. And I were graduate students in the same lab in Madison. Say hello to him. And then Perlman later became dean at Wisconsin.
So here I am at meeting President Vicker. And I said, yeah, I know Dave Perlman. Oh, and he's now keeping, he's both Dean and maintain his research program. And Mac's comment was, well, it's only Dean of the pharmacy school.
I went back and told Dean Wilson, I said, you got a problem, you got a big problem. He didn't have a problem that turns out. I mean, he went on to his retirement and so forth.
No matter everything is said, I've never heard of Mac firing anybody without due cause. But what happened getting on back to my own personal. I went up for promotion. And it was turned down.
This is happening to all over campus because he wanted a standard dossier where you use outside referees. Well, it threw my department. He didn't know what to do.
But to Wilson's credit, Dean Wilson's credit, who had been at Minnesota, and it Texas, he knew exactly where Mac was coming from and what had to be done. He says, okay, here is what we are going to do.
We got the outline. I need outside referees. And so I may have professors at school's function and form.
And then I got, I did get promoted the next time around. And then made it to professor on the first time around on that.
So, but that was happening all over campus. And not only were young faculty in Shell Shock, but you had department heads who had never been turned down all they do.
It was right, letters saying they wanted so and so promoted and tenured. And it was done. You had Dean who had never been turned down. And it was, I didn't look back on your lap.
But oh yeah, it was a traumatic time. There was no question about it. But the result was Oregon State University today.
And what I never have understood is why there's no building or anything like that named after him. There are young faculty. I have no idea who he, who Mac was.
And you give him a lot of credit for propelling university for it.
So, I would say he, without him, we would still be second fiddle to the University of Oregon. And I mean real second fiddle. I think Portland State could be a headless.
No, he knew what had to be done. And he pushed. And I said, he is, is one person that he was his own provost. We had a dean of faculty in those days, Dave Nicodemus, who was kind of the good cop.
And Mac was the bad cop as the president of the university. But I know, I know, and he had quite a temper. Boy, he could flare.
But I, I don't know if anybody who was out, out fired, who locked horns with him. He just let fly. And I just, I don't know if anybody who was.
And I'm not saying there wasn't. But he really followed protocol. When we did not grant tenure to a faculty member, boy, he wanted to make sure everything was dotted. And he reviewed it carefully.
I think one that he didn't want to get lost, it's obviously. But I think he, I think basically, have you ever read about this fellow who is a president for a long time at Boston? I want to say Boston. He did a Boston College or Boston University, Silverman, John Silverman.
And there's a review in the Wall Street Journal of a book he had written. Well, he's dead now so many a couple of years ago. But he brought to school, that school up into a major research university and hired top notch faculty. And he believed in academic freedom.
But he also wanted to lead an excellence. And it caused the real transformation. And I kind of look at the two people. Mac never wrote a book as far as I know.
As the two of the same type, they had this goal. And they know it could be done. And if I get the right faculty, I know it can be done. And he basically did.
What does he remember about him as a person? It sounds like you knew him a little bit. I don't know, kind of a personal level.
He was very distant. And I say we're in the same church. And he just never seemed to let his guard down till after he retired. He just lived over here.
A couple blocks away. And one day after he retired.
I don't know if he's here with a petition for a designer. Why be showed up to the house? Come on in.
Sat down on the couch out there. And just talked. He even talked about being hired and things. He'd just...
Everything was fine. He was retired now. There was no barrier between us.
There was a neighborhood dessert from our church. And we got the thing mixed up on the counter.
So my wife knocked. I pushed a tour bell. And they said, well we're here for the dessert.
Well, that was last night. It was last week. Oh gosh. He says, come on in. I think we have some pie. We have some cake.
And his life is always very gracious. And we sat down and visited for a while.
Well, what other colleagues of yours were important to you in OSU within Pharmacy or elsewhere?
Well, there was the 9th department head Bob Dorby, who was very good.
The one that we were basically parallel to each other was George Constantine.
Who's here? I mean, he's over-albuming, but he's not the one you could always interview.
Let's see. As far as contemporaries, I would say, those two for the most part.
Doing some research on Pharmacy is more recent here. Is there a couple of names that have stood out as people who made an impact on...
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm going to speak one more.
The dean, the gentleman who replaced Charlie Wilson with Dick O'Hall. Who was there for a long time?
Yes. And he once...he said, John, how would you like to be on the Board of Pharmacy?
And I thought, okay, that sounds like an intriguing deal because I wasn't setting the world on fire research-wise.
And this is a State Board of Pharmacy. Yes, a State Board of Pharmacy.
So I think I put my name in and the old guard in the profession that I'm not going to remember on the Board of Pharmacy.
It's ridiculous. And the vacancy came up again. He says, let's make another run at it.
And I don't know what I have behind the scenes, but I got appointed at the Board of Pharmacy.
Neil Goldsmith. Now, he didn't know me from out of it. It's all done by the appointments office.
And of course, check politics. The Board of Pharmacy, I'm sure, was not on the Goldsmith's political radar screen.
So I got on the Board. And there was an executive director on the Board, Ruth Vanderbier, at a real vision where pharmacy could go.
She had basically been the author of the Revive Pharmacy Practice Act, which gave Pharmacy a lot more responsibility in the State.
And I started to go to the National Association of the Board of Pharmacy and regional meetings.
I ended up offering a couple resolutions, got on to task force of the Board, ended up being on one of the permanent committees of the National Association Board of Pharmacy and on one of the exam committees for foreign pharmacy graduates.
So that, that, I would say Dick had a real impact. I was on the Board for the mandatory eight years. When I say mandatory, you can't exceed eight years.
And was President of the Board twice.
I was going to ask you about a couple of fellows from the pharmacy department or the school of pharmacy. It sounded like it made an impact through their research. And one of them was James Ares.
Oh, yes, yes. He was on sabbatical somewhere.
And I got a call from Professor Sandin, a microbiology. And I want to say it's Bill Sandin, but I may have the first name wrong, but anyway, Sandin.
And he wanted some way to develop some method of buffering bacterial cultures in the cheese making process.
And I said, well, the formulation person is Jim Ares. And so Jim comes back and they meet each other and they kept quite a collaboration going and had one of the most successful patents of that era.
And Jim may still, and I don't know if the college is still getting some money. Of course, Jim getting some money.
This is the time release. Time release, yes. Right. Yeah, Jim had, he had, he developed industrial contacts. He probably had one of the biggest graduate programs.
He believed he's completely retired on the coast now. And he no longer have a home here. Carvales. How about William Gerwig?
Oh, yes, yes. He and I actually co-taught in the biochemistry course. But Bill developed a fabulous natural products and was eventually hired away by the University of California at San Diego.
But he had a large program, a very large program.
He took a sabbatical in 1972, Carl Jarrassi. Yes. Only about that. Well, I wouldn't take a sabbatical. People do. And so we arranged for the house to be rented by, I think, a couple that was on sabbatical from somewhere else.
And went down, stayed at a rented house, went to the nearest team, over Polish couple who had not been back to Poland since the Second World War. And I think family there. Anyway.
So I worked in Carl Jarrassi's lab. He's quite an individual. And of course, the father's birth control pill.
And got four papers out. It was a natural products lab because without we're going to get really Sea Grant going. And we had various ideas. And somehow we never could tap into that well into the Sea Grant money here.
But we thought we'd get a marine natural products thing going. It never did work out. But yeah, it was a good year.
Did you get to know him very well? He's one of these people that has a fantastic memory. So he got to know you more than you got to know him.
I mean, I was working on one of the papers. And I said, I bend, I think, and I bend, I bend the cam abstracts. I'm not finding this reference. He got up and went over to his card file, pulled out something from don't ask how that paper was says here.
And he didn't do it in a way that felt like shrinking in the floor. And I don't know how I missed this. Well, I said, I did. You didn't have computer. I search in the cam abstracts in those days. It was all done manually with big thick volumes and fine print. But anyway, he came up here once he's he retired as a chemist and has written three or four novels and some plays.
Sort of a Renaissance man, I'd have to say. And he came up. I can't remember who brought him up. But I went over during the break, reintroduced myself. He seemed to remember who I was.
He's friends with Linus Pauling, who's also in the Stanford area at the time. Yeah. And I can't remember if I did go over here when Pauling's lectures are not falling came back to campus a few times too. It was you. Yes. Oh, yeah. And the only time I heard him on campus that I'm aware of. I can't remember if I went to any of the peace lectures later on.
I mean, after many years, wife. But there was that one time when the African American football players walked off the campus because of the beard incident with our moustache and with Deandre of the football coach.
And Pauling was to speak at Gil Colosseum and the students came in and Jensen was president. It was a it was an awkward situation.
And I think Jensen felt very hurt by that because I think they see it was a very fair man. But you're dealing with a powerful football coach who had powerful alumni behind him.
So it was an awkward situation. And I probably went ahead and gave a talk.
You mentioned Dean of all he was Dean for 22 years. The longest serving Dean of his generation in pharmacy apparently.
That sounds like there are at least a couple of changes that he invoked. And one of them you mentioned a little bit was emphasis on increased experience and patient care.
Well, that was going on during the I would say that that was a trend in pharmacy education all across the United States. And you would very I mean, he was going to make sure we stayed current.
As part of that, the curriculum added clinical components, including can I ask you to turn that off and I'll tell you why.
Act to.
So we were talking about changes in the curriculum and focus on clinical components, including communication skills.
Yeah, the history of communication has been a very interesting one for a long time. The pre pharmacy curriculum had some type of speech requirement.
And the question was always what is the appropriate type of speech requirement? Is it it? So I think the word expository speech where you get up and give your three minute speech or your five minute speech, which is not what pharmacists do.
They talk one in one like you and I are talking to each other. And so what you want is there. They're apparently it was a speech course that supposedly was more how to interact one on one rather than with an audience.
I'm not sure if there's still a speech requirement in the pre pharmacy curriculum or not. It wasn't there when I was an undergraduate. I can tell you that.
I had it in high school. But that what happened was was mandatory counseling. In fact, I was on the board of pharmacy when the mandatory constant requirement went in.
And it was happening across the United States. Part of it was patient better patient care. Part of it was get the pharmacists out there talking with the patient rather than hiding behind the counter and having some sales clerk and at all.
So one of our I guess called faculty, Marisa, director of student health service pharmacy, Bill Boyce, and actually pioneered the technique for how to consult a patient.
And there's a little card and there's three questions on it. I can't remember all of them how they went. But basically it was what did your physician tell you about this medicine.
So your first of all rather than get through this lecture and I'm you're trying to find out what they what the patient's understanding. So you're not talking down to them.
And that's also a good way of doing air checking the last minute because if you're handing them an antibiotic and the patient says it's for my high blood pressure, you know, just hang on a moment.
We got to check this out. But okay, we'll see what's the correct prescription.
Another question might be what did the any could elaborate on the response or yes, I see you have a good understanding.
What did the physician explain to you on how to take it? And you find out or do they realize they are to take it four meals or two hours after a meal.
And I can't remember if the third one, whether you have any other question you want to ask me or did the physician explain any of the pertinent side effects.
And there you're trying to you're not trying to scare the patient or they'll never take it. But you might also or if you do get a certain type of sensation, you need to either call your physician or call us rather than simply go up and give them a spiel.
So you're that you're trying to teach that type of communication on a one-on-one basis. Most of pharmacies are not even set up for it. So you're trying to have some place in a corner where nobody else can hear the conversation.
But depending on noise of the story is Fred Meyer, they probably can't hear it because of all the noise. Rises I think you can hear the conversation.
I have a silly question. I probably wouldn't even ask before how the pharmacists interpret the handwriting of doctors and the scripts that they receive. A lot of it is practice. A lot of it is now electronic transmission.
And one of the most important things is phone and find out what it is that was written. So there isn't any secret code.
No, no, and they're not supposed to write in Latin anymore. In fact, they don't know Latin.
It's kind of moving through your career.
I will. One of the one of the resolutions that we find I got through the National Association of Borders of Pharmacy was a test of spoken English.
Not written English. They're supposed to do that also. Spoken English is very interesting to see the opposition.
And of course there was all this about a political correctness, but you had to explain that the communication media is you could have a resident at a medical center who is from one country in Asia talking to a pharmacist who is from India.
And the only thing they've got in common is the English language. Not saying the Asian one maybe that is good in English is the Indian one, but the point is airline pilots and the control towers use English.
So now if a person a pharmacist is dual language so they can talk in another language and explain the directions or hand the person a information sheet in the patient's native language some of the computer programs will do that.
Great. That's excellent.
But still got to still got to be able to speak it.
I want to ask you about you served on a National Science Foundation panel for instructional scientific equipment.
I did. You're right. Forgotten about that. Yeah, it's down in I think Los Angeles. I think we all went down there. It was for undergraduate research and it was a very interesting panel.
So in time I did and I'm not quite sure how my name got in there. Got never got funded by it. I'm not sure if I replied. But what was fascinating was you had good solid liberal art schools.
The Lewis and Clark this date to Lewis and Clark's the reads the will amits. For example, applying for they wanted a new NMR a new updated.
Inferred spectres, putometer for their lab. They would be used and they outline the courses that would be used in.
And also how it would function for undergraduate research projects. And we.
Oh, and they would also be able to show how they would be able to support the instrument that they had the technicians available to keep it going or experience faculty and you'd fund those.
Then you would get a little small liberal arts college that maybe had one chemist.
Two of they were lucky. Who wanted this to be piece of equipment. And you say, how are they going to maintain it? Do you understand how it works?
Where is the course that's going to be used in? We wouldn't fund it. Or you got the application from the chemistry department at the University of California or the University of Wisconsin and Madison who just had to have a new hot shot NMR.
And they were going to let the undergrad was walked by essentially. No, we didn't fund that either.
So we basically funded.
Liberal arts program. Well, it didn't have to be I'm sorry. I don't want to apply. It had to be a private liberal arts school.
A school like Western probably would not have any problem either. They had to have a substantial. We were doing it in the chemistry area now, please keep that in mind.
Speaking of the discipline, they had to have a core of faculty. One thing that really helped them was where did they have a program that met the undergrad with standards of the American chemical society, which means they had to have enough that had basically faculty in each of the disciplines, organic, physical, analytical.
It seemed a really important point in the modern history of the College of Pharmacy came in 1988 when the satellite campus was formed at OHSU.
That is still a dynamic situation. The Oregon State like some of the other pharmacy schools of history, historical, are not out on a campus where there's a medical center.
And then the big debate is does the school move to where the medical center is or is the school stay where it is and try to do the satellite campus.
And of course we did the latter. Part of it is how would you move our whole research emphasis and productivity. We are very productive.
If you take a look at the amount of grant money, this pharmacy school is now bringing in. How would it be situated? Where would be the support infrastructure?
I mean there's quite a dynamic support all across campus. There's the mass spec centers, there's the NMR centers and so forth. So there's a real good synergism on a campus like this.
And so how would that be handled in Portland area? Because there's not a major, excuse me, Portland State, but there's not a major research university there.
Portland State has got some real strong areas, don't please don't misunderstand me. And OHSU is a medical center. They're not teaching the basic science courses that would feed into a medical center.
And the students all come in for somewhere else. So that's one thing.
So initially was to get the clinical program established up there for the fourth year and try to get rotations.
And that took a lot of missionary work, you might say, to get the medical center to accept it. It seems to be working very well now.
It really is. And of course there's both the medical center, OHSU, and there is the VA. And there's the other big hospitals, legacy, Providence, Kaiser.
There is. I'm trying to think of basic pharmaceutical sciences. And I have the impression that I want to emphasize this only in impression that there is some pharmaceuticals now up in Portland, as opposed to just the clinical.
Well another important moment came 11 years later when OHSU decided no longer to offer the bachelor's degree in pharmacy and focus solely on the farm D.
Oh, yes, that's got a very interesting history.
The question was, was money for one thing to find answer because you need an additional faculty, particularly in the clinical area.
And you had to pay going wages because they could all work in the private sector.
So the question came up, and I remember Dick talking about Dick O'Hall, talking about it, was, do we start a small farm D program and just kind of shoehorn it in?
And there was some type of educational coordinating committee that was made to approve new programs, good limited duplication.
I think it's passed by the wayside now. And the chair of that committee made the comment. He says, no, you wait until we can have a good program. We want excellent program.
The other thing they did at the state level was saying, you can't have a professional doctor program unless the students have a bachelor's degree.
And there are these pharmacy schools, unfortunately, in my opinion, who a student can go through and get a doctor pharmacy degree and not have any bachelor's degree.
Well, can you imagine a medical physician not having a bachelor's degree as far as I know, as Dennis do?
I think all the lawyers now have bachelor's degree before they get their doctor, jurisprudence.
And so we worked out essentially a seven year program, three year pre-farmacy.
We made arrangements with general science that they would accept courses in the first professional year, maybe some in the second, towards the general science degree.
So if they don't have a bachelor's degree, they will by the end of their second professional year and they have to, before they take their last two years.
Now it turns out I believe over 90% are coming in with bachelor's degrees now.
But we were one of the first schools to require this bachelor's degree requirement.
I think Ohio State was coming to the other OSU ironically, or coincidentally, or whatever.
I believe the University of California San Francisco is always, oh, I should say we're one of the first.
They're always, they're one of the pioneers for the farm D program.
And I think they always required a bachelor's degree.
I think they always did.
And that may have been true of USC also.
My understanding is a large number of the state pharmacy schools, the well-established state, you know, at the state universities,
are now, have got so much in their pre-farmacy that essentially there's a bachelor degree requirement.
So they don't know about Pacific, for example, if a person who didn't walk in office three to four years or a year later,
actually they have a year around curriculum three and a half years, walk out with a farm D without a bachelor's degree.
I don't know, frankly.
Well, it sounds like this shift to the pharmacy led to the closer entire of the OSU became a degree between the two universities.
Because it required a lot more clinical faculty, it required more clerkships.
And more, making more rounds than that.
Yes, yes.
There's no, there's no question about it.
Want to talk a little bit more about your career.
You mentioned your time on the Oregon Board of Pharmacy.
One of, it's one of the interesting things that you were involved with there was assisting with the interpreting
and implementation of the plan for assisted suicide law.
Want to talk about that?
Yes.
That was a fascinating experience.
Here was a situation.
You had the potentiality of a pharmacist who was opposed to it, receiving a prescription
and not realizing why they were dispensing it.
And in fact, they, under the patient constant, they make a lot and give a bunch of goofy advice.
And may not even realize what was happening.
And then you had the situation where they had a winemain.
I'm not going to dispense this and pull the back.
So, there were various scenarios.
The sponsors of the Physician-Sister Suicide made no if and some butts about it.
There was to be nothing hidden from the pharmacist nurses.
Anybody, it was to be an open process.
Anybody who did not want to participate, needing, and they actually had networks of physicians and pharmacists and nurses.
So forth, who were positive.
And they could always put a family in touch, get them into the system.
So, we went back and forth with the Board of Medical Examineries.
No, no, scratch that.
We went back and forth with the Oregon Medical Association.
It turned out that we've seen pretty well, have the support of the physicians, including the officers.
But there was a lobbyist who has taken his cue from the American Medical Association.
And if a physician doesn't want to tell a pharmacist anything, that's it.
God is spoken.
And so, we finally wrote a rule that said physicians had to tell the pharmacists.
Well, all of a sudden you had the Board of Pharmacy write a rule covering the pharmacists.
Board of Medical Examineries were not upset because they were being shoved, not pushed, not to.
So we now had our rule.
And the Physician, the Oregon Medical Association, they're lobbyists.
Didn't like it at all.
So, of course, by this time I believe Dr. Kitsoper was governor.
And so, in the meantime, we were trying to get through a collaborative drug treatment through,
which we had a trained general, says we had the authority to do,
but the drug industry didn't like it.
And this is where pharmacists can be involved in working out the treatment, modalities, and the dosage and so forth.
So, another Board member and I were called into the governor's health advisor office.
And basically, what the governor did, he told the medical board,
you take that Board of Pharmacy rule and you rewrite it with your name on it instead of their name.
And you push it through, which they did.
If that day was a draft and we approved it, that was fine.
We didn't care. All we wanted was the pharmacists and all of these prescriptions were coming through.
And so, we told the health advisor, that's fine with us.
And then he says, so what now is it you're trying to do?
And we mentioned collaborative drug therapy.
And this fellow head was a former EMT or something on the ambulance.
That's how he knew Kitsoper.
They were fishing buddies from Southern Oregon.
And he looked at, says, well, is that like when I'm on the ambulance, I can put Startheiv and for a person in cardiac arrest,
and said, yes, he says, oh, okay, you got it.
I'll tell a lot of this from the OMA that it's going to go through.
So, we got what we wanted and the physicians got, well, they know they got what they wanted,
but at least they have face saving on it.
So, yeah, that's the story.
We're all happy campers now.
You mentioned to the Eastern and Foreign Pharmacy Graduate Equivalency Examination Committee.
Yeah, that's the exam committee with the National Association Board of Pharmacy.
What did that entail?
Oh, you had a significant number of graduates of Foreign Pharmacy Schools that wanted to immigrate to the United States and practice pharmacy.
And we had no, there's no equivalent of a basic pharmacical, a basic medical exam, basic medical science exam.
There's something that medical schools have after a couple of years, I guess everybody takes this test before they go out in the clinch.
I'm not really, I'm really not quite sure how it works, but there's, there apparently is some type of standard test.
There's nothing like that with pharmacy.
So, this is the closest thing to it.
And there's other requirements for the graduate.
They've had to have so many years in a pharmacy school that has to meet certain curricular standards and so on.
And there is a test of spoken English by the way, they have to pass.
And of course, they test the English of the foreign languages, they have to pass that also.
So basically, there's a bank of questions that we work on, I have to be in the medicinal chemistry area.
That's supposed to be equivalent to what, if they can pass it, then they have at least the minimum standards of graduating the dike-dactic coursework in a pharmacy school.
Now, they still have to do their interning.
And that, that sort of thing.
So, I was in the medicinal chemistry. We meet twice a year.
We would come up with questions, just like SATs, any of these questions that are on there that are going to count,
and there's questions that are being tested to see if they're discriminating or they're too difficult or they're too easy.
And so, we would be working on new questions plus trying to fix the questions that didn't test right.
And one of the things I did was, in the pioneer, as they developed this exam, the chemistry portion, some of the chemical structures were pretty bad.
They were bad. So I said, well, I've got a, I've got a chem draw program, which was sort of the standard.
And so I worked out a deal with them. I didn't get paid, but I redrew hundreds and hundreds of structures using the same program.
Something else that you worked on that is interesting to me, and my background with Linus Paul, he developed them all for General Amesthesia.
And I understand that that's something you studied to the controversy over in General Amesthesia.
Well, I, that's one of the contracts with the Army.
And we were trying to see if there was a, a receptor for it.
I think there is because they, they've got optically active, a stereotypical, sit left and right, and molecules.
One is active, the other is not. So there must be some type of receptor. But that never led to anything.
Do I understand correctly? There is still no accepted theory of why General Amesthesia is.
I think there is some theories for it, but I'm not, there's some about nerve conduction where it's going depolarization neurons.
I think there is some of that now because they can visualize the brain so much differently nowadays with the various types of scans, the PET scanners and all that, but they can get some idea where, which neurons are firing, which are the brains are reacting in certain ways.
So I think, I think they're closer.
You retired in 2003 after 37 years in the College of Pharmacy.
And you saw a lot of change, and we could reflect on the changes in the college over that, of course, at that time.
Well, I mean, we've been talking about them.
But BASY has started out to be a traditional five year bachelor degree program.
But there's no chemistry. Pharmaceutical analysis, formulation, for basic pharmaceuticals, what they called physical pharmacy, dosing standard classic pharmacology.
And they were still teaching pharmacy management if you're going to have your own drugstore.
So I think there was some accounting in there.
And as it became more and more obvious that pharmacists were going to be employees.
You saw the management evolve into pharmacy, socially, economic.
So you started, they started to be the discussion of healthcare delivery, which population groups can get it.
And why, which ones cannot get it, and why not.
Various types of insurance models out there.
Then, as I said, the labs disappeared as far as the pharmaceutical sciences went.
I think they still do a little bit of compounding, some basic compounding.
But I think that's about it.
And I'm not even sure it's a small lab.
And they got some sterile hoods.
And I think that's about all they're doing.
I think I may be wrong on that, you'd have to ask somebody, like the associate dean or somebody to ask them.
Big emphasis on patient care, big emphasis on the clinical pharmacy aspect, which is,
a person has a certain disease or a couple of diseases.
And this drug causes this side effect and this drug.
And our person shows up and they're taking six or eight, not exaggerating.
Six or eight different drugs.
And can that be whittled down to three or four?
Because they take a drug to get a side effect, they get a drug to treat the side effect, and so on.
It gets messy.
And of course, with the area diabetes, just use as an example.
Not used to be basically insulin and a couple oral medications.
Well, there are several oral and there's a whole bunch of other drugs that have been discovered that affect the pancreas, affect the alpha cells or the beta cells.
And then there's even looking at the auto-eminology aspect of it all on the clinical side.
I know that one of the pursuits that you've followed retirement is you're going to your Medicare resource.
And this date is called Shiba Senior Health Benefit Assistance Program,
which that notebook is sitting over there on your side here.
Nationally, it's SHIP, Senior Health Insurance Assistance Program,
which the A haven't been dropped.
Until very recently, we were part of Center for Medicare and Medicaid Services.
I'd have to go to the computer and find out who the new federal agency is we're on.
We are moving under.
I don't guess the move is not complete yet.
And I'm not sure politically what the heck was going on and we got moved.
But we go, I started back in 2005 when the Part D drug propants began.
The person who was the coordinator was looking for volunteers desperately because they needed people to put the drugs into what was called Medicare.gov plan finder.
And find out what Part D plan would work for them and I was retired from pharmacy.
So I've been better than ever since I was Shiba Lite for a couple years and then full.
I think I'm the senior one in Ben County now, I believe.
Anyway, we are, of course, go through training.
We have to be recertified every year.
We go through a background check, which includes fingerprinting.
Obviously, we've signed all the confidentiality agreements.
We log every contact.
It goes into a, obviously, secure database.
And our password changes every two months.
I also am one of the instructors.
We either call it new to Medicare or ABCD,
some Medicare Part A, Part B, Part C, Part D.
That's a two hour free course.
Most of them are taught over here at the Benton Center because they have the parking and they have the classroom with computer facilities.
And I'm currently on phone duty now.
Oh, I should explain.
If you have a Medicare question or you want to talk to a counselor,
there's two ways of doing it.
One is to call the toll free number and say them,
which you can get off of the web, put the port of Kachiba in and you can take it right there.
And you punch in your zip code and automatically is referred then to Albany.
We, our sponsor here is RSVP Retire Senior Volunteer Program.
And the sponsors for the different Shiba slash ships, very important.
It's not known to County Department of Health, I guess, is their sponsor.
And I can't tell you who the sponsors are in other counties.
It's Lynn and Benton and Lincoln are together.
But anyway, it'll go into the RSVP office at the Consulate Government's office on Queens Avenue over there in Albany.
And then an email will go out to the appropriate county with referral.
And I'm on phone duty.
And the main reason for that is, I can't verify, may have mentioned when you came in.
My wife is on foster home and she's actually under hospice.
So I go up three times a day and feed her, excuse me.
And I can't get up to the senior center.
So I get the referrals and so forth.
Which is kind of interesting. I kind of like that. I enjoy it.
Almost better than, I don't mean anti-face to face, but you can,
you can get quite a bit of information over the phone.
And we have Google Calendar to make appointments I can even make an appointment for them.
It's just a seemingly complicated subject to be dealing with.
One of the things we mentioned in our classes, and we'll tell clients when they almost are feeling sheepish,
when we worked and you had employer health insurance, you took the employer plan.
That was it. I mean, you might have had a choice to in a high deductible or low deductible,
but basically that was it folks.
And they may or may not have had dependency coverage.
Okay, now you're reaching 65.
What are you going to do? Are you going to keep working?
Or as your company or your employer says, fine.
If then are you going to draw Social Security or not?
And a lot of people think, well, if I don't draw Social Security, I don't go into Medicare.
And no, wrong. At age 65, you have got to enroll in Medicare or you're going to get penalized.
And the penalties can be significant, by the way.
Unless you happen to be an employer group health plan of 20 or more employees, at which case you can delay it.
So Medicare has been described as yes, no, and with the following exceptions.
But it is universal health care single payer for the over 65 and over and for disabled.
It interfaces with private insurance to pick up deductibles and co insurance.
And this is where a lot of people then should I go with a Medicare supplement, known as a Medigap,
or should I go with an Advantage plan? And if I decide to go with an Advantage plan, which one should I go with?
Advantage to go with a Medigap, which one should I go with?
So there are these various. And then there's the fall open enrollment period where people can change plans.
And now with the Affordable Care Act, the Medicare crowd also start making appointments because they see all this publicity on the Affordable Care Act.
They want to know how this affects them. It doesn't. Well, it does, but there's nothing they can do about it.
Well, the effect is basically beneficial. The donut hole will slowly disappear in the Part D.
So there's a clue I need for people like you to help people navigate.
Oh, it keeps us mentally alert, poorly straight.
Well, I'll just take a couple more questions for you. The new building in Portland just opened up.
I haven't seen it, but they say it's very nice. The other tower, the end of its beautiful view of the river, they could even watch barges being watched.
But I have not seen the new one, other than dry buy it. It's going up.
It just strikes me as being another important chapter, I guess, in the history of pharmacy.
I think they worked very, they being the current dean and the previous dean.
It worked very hard to make sure we had the floor space and the labs and so forth to be a fully not move us there, but to make sure that the faculty there had the resources and are to advance.
A number of them are hired as clinical assistant, clinical associate professors.
That's a non-taniour track type of deal with a revolving fixed term type of thing.
But they're a tenure track faculty up there too.
The last thing I want to ask you about is that the university has changed so much in the last few years and continues to change and grow.
That's a good perspective on where I always use heading right now.
Well, I have the impression that we want to be the strongest university in the state, which I have no problem with.
We're in Carson, every county.
I think our relationship with the state is quite good.
The amount of extramural funding that we bring in is phenomenal.
It's not just NIH. I mean, there's ag, there's Sea Grant, all that type of thing.
I think the question that OSU has to really wrestle with as do any research university is making sure that the undergraduate student is able to do research.
It's sure that the undergraduate still has a good education experience, which at a good research university they can.
You have good students and you can get them involved in the searching out at new knowledge.
It can be a fabulous, fabulous experience.
But the faculty have to want to enjoy working with undergraduates, not just their graduate students and their postdocs.
And for that young assistant professor, that can be a time-telling. That can be a strain.
Because it's hard to get the funding. I mean, back in the days when the funding was more plentiful, it probably wasn't.
But they are struggling to bring that money in.
And they're hired now with fairly generous startup packages.
And they return the university wants them to produce. You might almost pay it back.
So it's a rough go. And I have to be very candid and say, would I today start out the same way?
I think pharmacy was fine. And with the clinical pharmacy and so forth, I might find that more...
I'm more interesting. Many more instincts are wrong word. But I don't know if I would like to be under that constant gun of getting funded and get it renewed.
So I think that's my temperament. I felt very fortunate that Dickel Ball kind of took me under his wing there and said, why didn't you?
I think he saw it, was going to pull in big bucks. Why don't you look at the regulatory. And I think I was successful there.
Well Dr. Bach, thank you very much. This has been very educational for me. I appreciate you giving us this time to share your memories of pharmacy.
Well, thank you for coming. And whatever I said, I'll be dying.